[Music]
all right
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream the part where we a
your cues and
what and and that's what we're gonna do
as soon as we know what they are it's
hard
those of you who don't do this for a
living probably don't know but without
the cues it's hard to deliver it's hard
to deliver the A's so it's not actually
that hard that's what we do in the first
hour
that is deep and true and I did not
anticipate this I'm now backed into a
corner having uh established a position
that I no longer believe in so um you've
been there before you're excellent at
navigating these kinds of waters all
right well then I uh I'm going to
correct my position awesome it is very I
wouldn't say it's easy but uh it's
certainly possible to deliver answers to
questions that have not been delivered
to anticipate them really which also
starts with an A complexifying things
but
um maybe um maybe it's time to talk to
move on to the part where we get to that
and I can begin to try to live down this
embarrassing episode I'm sort of
enjoying this part
you would be no that's not fair
um we do not have a question from
Discord the Discord server this week
every week uh we invite them to send in
a question that they most want uh to
hear answered this is a Discord server
you can access through either of our
patreons
um if I will check my email throughout
this if a question comes in we will get
to it but until then we will start off
with the questions that we have in front
of us
first question from
darkhorsesmissions.com where you too can
ask your questions seems like keeping
everyone afraid alarmed angry and
divided is great business for a ton of
people and companies if things start to
get better will we know hella we know
and do you think things can get better
many thanks
um things can get better will they
know
and your point is right that there are
people who are utterly dependent on our
division and this is something we've
been talking about repeatedly from the
beginning of Dark Horse and indeed you
know far earlier than that the hidden
tribes report which we don't talk about
that frequently anymore but uh
nonetheless revealed exactly the pattern
there is a large majority of us
that mostly agree on how things should
go mostly agree on where we are we are
not in perfect agreement about anything
but even the most difficult issues the
ones on which we are supposed to not be
able to reach agreement
such as abortion we actually mostly
agree and
um you know
I would say there I actually had a
number of conversations uh while I was
on my trip
with conservatives who wanted to know
why I won't just join them
um and I told them look there are some
things that I think conservatives just
simply don't have right
and I think it's kind of my job and our
job to keep pushing them to see these
things important ones including
the question of environmental
degradation right conservatives are
often very quick to dismiss this as
narrowly about global warming about
which many do not believe and that's a
mistake for multiple reasons but even if
you took global warming off the table
the environmental degradation of our era
is so spectacular and most of it
irreversible yeah well I will say two
things to that because you know although
you wouldn't necessarily be able to tell
from Dark Horse
um the you know
maintaining wild nature on this planet
is one of the things that is most
important to both of us
and
um
I think a the two things I wanted to say
in direct response which aren't exactly
related to another are a uh hunters and
fishermen
who often tend to be more politically
conservative not in not inherently we
have plenty of fishermen Hunter friends
who aren't but that is at least the
reputation and certainly there are many
conservative hunters and fishermen maybe
in part because such people are more
likely to live in rural areas and having
a rural lifestyle is more likely to have
you be either conservative or
libertarian to like just like keep your
paws off what I'm doing and let me live
my life
um they you know people who actually
hunt and fish without a lot of betting
technology
see the changes and they care deeply
about them and they may be driven by
slightly different
immediate you know proximate motives
than we would be but not but not really
ultimately and in many ways they have
they have a kind of
um like populist database
that is remarkable in terms of being
able to see you know like gardeners
background gardeners and and such
understand a lot of things about
phonology about the timing of when
plants flower and fruit and thus you can
see how seasons are changing
um and you know how spring is coming
earlier in Northern climes and such in
many places and and later and some as
well so like you get these sorts of well
it wasn't done to do science but you end
up with years and years and years of
love people who are paying attention to
a pattern I've always gone a hunt there
and there are less of them now and you
know or I couldn't walk through what I
used to be able to walk through because
it was always Frozen and now it's not
you know that sort of thing so I will
say that there's at least a considerate
sort of cohort of of people who are
often conservatives who really do
understand how much the environment is
changing
um
oh and the other the other thing I would
say is that another group of people who
are often politically conservative
um are and you know this is this is not
all Christians for sure but people who
um wear their Christianity forward who
you know who who who want you to know
about the Christianity early on so I'm
not just talking about evangelicals and
fundamental fundamentalists but
um will often and I you know I believe
that this comes out of scripture
although I don't know scripture well
enough to know for sure
um basically say you know no all of that
is put here for us to use and therefore
and therefore we can do with it what we
will and I have seen that from some
prominent conservatives and on that
point I disagree completely I you know
it it is not put here for us and
I do disagree completely
you disagree completely with the modern
interpretation of this
it does come from scripture and because
it comes from scripture you're dealing
with something that's a great example in
fact of something that a metaphor that
was useful that has aged into the
opposite of useful it's now a lethal
Hazard but when you were relegated to
simple analog tools right uh when you
were dealing you know the amount of
damage you can do to a forest with a
machete is a lot less than you can do
with a chainsaw which is a lot less than
you can do with one of these machines
that can strip a tree in 30 seconds and
so the point is the belief that this is
all here for you make what use of it you
will is a motivating belief that becomes
a toxic and dangerous belief yeah and
it's and it's a way of
reifying a hierarchy which most people
do kind of live by like you know you
honor you honor other people you protect
other people before you protect it you
know you you protect that person rather
than that tree if you have to make a
choice between the two things right
right so uh you know at a small scale
which is all that was available
um at the point that scripture was being
written it can make sense as a rubric
for living your life yep
um all right so I interrupted you no go
on so anyway what I would what I would
say is there are places that you and I
in particular disagree with our many
many friends on the right now there are
lots of places in which we don't in
which they are conserving but we would
call the gains of past liberals and we
are in alignment I would say that there
is a there's a fundamental difference
between left and right in terms of
assessing how well we have done right we
agreed almost entirely
on the goal until very recently and for
those of us who have been jettisoned
from the left because the left has
changed it's objective and we are now
homeless and we are looking at people on
the right who are defending the things
that we believed in and still believe in
there is still a remaining difference if
we say well all right
all the reasonable people are Against
Racism
right all the reasonable people are for
equality of opportunity
uh to the extent practical what we
disagree on is how equivalent the
opportunities are right conservatives
are often dismissive they see well this
group of immigrants does very well you
know and they have been uh transported
uh here uh why when the southern group
of immigrants has done less well and
there are often reasons for this that we
don't get into but well also
historically left and right disagree not
just about what we see as the current
state but about what we think the best
solution to to fix the problem would be
and so I would say it's not that we as
still liberals would say
um oh it's all fine now no there are
still
um there's still inequalities
um that that that could be made less and
equal that could be made more equal but
the methods that are being proposed by
the new left by the woke left
um are
going to create much greater inequality
and and disaster well
the new left is trying to get somewhere
that we never agreed on and it's trying
to get there with tools that are absurd
right but they're but they're you they
they are acting as if it is they are
aiming for the conclusion that everyone
on the left had already
agreed was honorable yeah they pretend
but for those of us who haven't lost our
minds right there is
disagreement on how close we are to the
objective there is very little
disagreement on where we're supposed to
go there's disagreement on how close we
are to the objective and what are the
right remedies and in fact the right
remedies you know there was a time
earlier in my life I would have defended
affirmative action it wouldn't defend it
now I would say it is Justified but not
a good it doesn't work it's not a good
solution and so the question is well all
right let's talk about what does work
and you know use that to cover the
distance about which we don't fully
agree but in any case in answer to the
person's question
there is overwhelming agreement on what
a good Society is supposed to do the
differences we have in that group that
experiences overwhelming agreement that
very large majority actually that
experiences overwhelming agreement
something like 67 percent in the hidden
drives report
um the differences we have are small and
navigable right which is why Unity 2020
started with the premise that all we
need are people in the top office who
have three characteristics that they are
capable courageous Patriots right it
doesn't there's no requirement on what
their value system is because anybody in
that group right if you're capable
and you are a patriot and therefore are
interested in making the country good
and you're courageous enough to face
down what will oppose you then the point
is well we can just be reasonable about
what the best remedies are and what is
the evidence about how close we've
gotten and how much room is there left
and right those are very very solvable
problems so I will say one of the things
I'm hopeful about
in the case of what DeSantis is up to is
that actually it does sort of have this
flavor about well let's just assess
where we actually are and what it is
that might be done and you know
hopefully that's not political it
shouldn't be yeah right that's what
that's the opposite of politics
isn't
but already with the clip that you
showed of Colbert you know it's be it's
it's being actively politicized well it
has to be because uh Colbert whether
Colbert understands what he's part of or
not
he is
um a key node in a viciously political
absolutely anti-patriotic movement that
has co-opted lots of people who
basically have gotten into the habit of
thinking oh the blue team is the
compassionate team uh well [ __ ] not
anymore yeah man's a tool yeah he is and
it's sad because
um
Once Upon a Time
he was a very important road to Insight
about what was absurd on the
conservative side and now he is a
demonstration of what is absurd on the
liberal side
not as useful
all right
my sister gave me an ultimatum get
whooping cough booster or don't see her
newborn a preemie for 18 months
even pre-covered I doubted any job
safety or ability to prevent
transmission now it's worse what to do
I don't know I didn't actually know
so I haven't thought about whooping
cough vaccine in in the last three years
um
you know we're vaccinated against it I
presume if that was being done when we
were kids our kids are yeah oh it's
pertussis that's right it's pertussis
and our kids certainly are
um but I don't remember ever getting a
booster
I don't I don't remember ever getting
asked to get a booster for whooping
cough so that's straight so
I can't speak to the
um what is the nature of this this
vaccine and you know what what do we
think we understand about its safety and
efficacy
um so completely anecdotally I will say
I can't remember ever being advised or
having it be advised that our kids get
boosters for pertussis for whooping
cough even
when there was a pertussis outbreak at
one point in their Elementary School
yeah which we've seen we've seen a
couple of those we've seen a couple of
those right and no one ever said like oh
you adults should probably have your
titers checked and get you know get a
booster never heard that done well so I
don't I'm the strikes me is coming out
of the left field a little bit so I
agree
I think you've named one of the things
that a rational response would involve
which is
get your booster is always a dumb piece
of advice unless you can be certain that
tighter is low what we are coming what
we are becoming aware of is that
actually
and this is something you and I were
growing suspicious of even when we had
our kids you know
almost you know a couple decades ago
the
um
the problem is we don't properly
understand the tensions in the immune
system and therefore the cost of each
vaccination for overall immunity for
natural immunity and for innate immunity
those two being distinct right and so
anyway if you're tighter
is high enough to reflect ongoing
immunity then you shouldn't want any
booster on that front right right so the
fact that we don't test that it's just
like well vaccines are effectively free
why don't you take a booster but What's
It Gonna Hurt well here's what's going
to hurt natural and innate immunity you
know
Etc so
the problem is the what to do about the
whooping cough I don't know because I
haven't thought about that vaccine I
couldn't even tell you whether it is a
adjuvanted killed virus vaccine in which
case I would be very hesitant about it
or if it is an attenuated virus vaccine
in which case I might consider it yeah
um
but the larger problem is
you know I can now say look I don't it
would take a very serious scenario for
me to contemplate a killed virus
adjuvented vaccine at this point and I
might I would want to know what I can't
know which is
what is the rational response to having
had such a vaccine should you go on an
extremely simple diet of things that
don't tend to produce allergies for two
weeks after you've had one maybe it's 24
hours I don't know I don't you know it's
an obvious question somebody should have
studied the answer to but I would be
very hesitant about an adjuvented killed
virus vaccine I will be less hesitant
about a attenuated virus vaccine though
I am aware that it has a special Hazard
to it I think that Hazard is one that
you and I have the tools to understand
and it's very unlikely it goes bad
um but the overarching question is could
you trust any Authority that now told
you ah
that pertussis vaccine
safe and effective and it's like well
I've now seen those authorities lie
through their teeth so that I'm not I'm
not happy that I'm in a position where I
can't take any of that evidence
seriously but I don't know what part of
it is polluted by whom
well I'm wondering too this this raises
the question of
you know what what are the decisions
based on
that say well this vaccine you just get
once and then you're done it is one and
done
which ones which is most of the vaccines
that most adult Americans have
um which ones are understood somehow to
be on a regular cycle as if everyone's
bodily response to vaccine won't vary so
I'm thinking here of yellow fever which
is understood to you be oh you should
get your booster 10 years after getting
the first one or you know as soon as
you're going to be exposed again
like okay hopefully that 10 years was
based on something but I don't know what
that was and wouldn't that vary between
individuals or third category uh which
is like rabies
um which we are both vaccinated against
uh where it is understood that
um and I can't remember what the
periodicity is but it may be something
like 10 years where
every 10 years if you continue to be
exposed because for instance you're
working on bats wild bats
um you get your titers checked that is
the first step you do not get a shot
first you get your titers checked and if
your titers are fine I don't know what
the what the points are uh what the what
the recommended levels are but if you're
fine you're fine you don't get another
shot
so why why is there anything in that
second category why isn't yellow fever
like rabies like oh you get your titers
checked is it not possible if so why not
what's going on there
and why is it and this may just just be
an Immunology question but why do some
diseases uh warrant a re-up and some
don't and you'll maybe I don't know this
has just occurring to me maybe because
the two examples I just came up with are
diseases that most Americans don't run
into very often the idea is that if it's
like MMR if you're talking about your
measles most your bella vaccine that
these are circulating to some degree and
so your body is Con is occasionally
getting exposed and so your immune
system is a little bit activated with
regard to those whereas if it's yellow
fever if it's rabies you're not unless
unless you've gone and you're living in
a place where yellow fever for instance
is endemic you're not going to expose
much and therefore you might expect
their immune system has basically ramped
down its response all right a couple
things to add yeah just in sort of
building this model yeah
one the two diseases you mentioned
yellow fever and rabies are both
contracted
by something that penetrates the skin
true so that's some place that an
injected vaccination is actually well
positioned to address rather than giving
somebody an injection for a respiratory
virus where you may not have created the
Immunity on your mucosal surface where
you need it right okay cool
second thing is
um the problem with titers what I would
now want to know with respect to titers
is Titus is you can't get rabies from uh
droplets do you have to get bitten
you can it is quite rare okay maybe that
doesn't matter no but it's a fair point
there are cases where people have gotten
you know
p in the eye in a bat cave or something
like that that's what I thought yeah or
maybe it's respiratory but maybe it's
only highly vascularized tissue yeah I'm
not sure I think it is possible but
almost all cases come from but yellow
fever is entirely vectoring through
mosquito through correct okay
second thing is that titer is kind of a
bad these are all things that we've
learned here but tighter is about
antibodies and your best defense against
a virus tends to be on the T Cell side
where you have something analogous to
antibodies but it's affixed to the T
cells it's the receptor and so your
titer is an indirect measure of how
effective that that shot remains but I
guess you have no way to do the direct
measure is that right I bet you it's not
no way but I bet you it's so expensive
that Nobody Does it
um but maybe the idea is
if you're it's possible for your titer
that is your antibodies to have dropped
to a very low level and you to still
have T Cell immunity but it's very
unlikely that if your B cell immunity
that is your antibodies are still high
that your T Cell immunity has failed you
right so that's possible but the titer
is a conservative proxy
but
so I'm wondering if the reason that the
only place where we have been told get
your tighter checked rather than get
your shot is that the rabies vaccine
probably because it is so rarely
administered
is if I recall correctly absurdly
expensive I
that's true anymore certainly when we
got it uh it was we if I remember
correctly I think it was developed in
Michigan and therefore not only did the
University pay for it but because we're
in the state where it's developed it was
cheaper as long as you dressed in Maize
and Blue when you came in for your vet
something and you know some of the story
sounds spacious but like as I remember
we were both the University was going to
pay for a certain amount and because we
lived in the right state
it was free to us but yes it was I think
my recollection is that it was paid for
for us because it was understood to be
part of our graduate work and so they
didn't feel like having graduate
students Keel over from rabies yeah it's
a bad look it is I mean it's a froth
again
bad luck yeah um so anyway I think the
point is because the thing is so
expensive probably because it's so very
rarely applied right you have to
actually Source it
um you know it was like many hundreds of
dollars per dose yeah no one's got it on
hand or right and the idea is that I
think what I think the bottom line on
this question is that what we have is a
medical blind spot where because it's
hard to detect the harms that are
Downstream of hey you've had too many
vaccinations and they're pulling your
immune system in too many different
directions simultaneously or whatever it
does terms are most mostly uncoupled
from the moment right we got so used to
the idea that vaccines were a Magic
Bullet that was essentially cost free
and gave you superhuman in fact this is
what we tell children like this is you
know Yep this is your superhero shot
um we got so used to that style of
thinking that we just lost our ability
to think critically about the actual
trade-offs involved in these things and
in the case of rabies the cost is so
high that the financial trade-off caused
people to think about it differently
than they do the other things that's my
guess
um oh
yeah so that
yeah what to do with a sister who's
given you an ultimatum I you know a
sister gives you that kind of ultimatum
presumably thinks that she's protecting
her baby but um well here's what I would
say to the sister I guess
I would say look
it is not irrational to have concerns
about
vaccine safety and Effectiveness in this
day and age and pertussis is
particularly likely to be lethal in
babies especially if it's a preemie
right like this is one of these age
stratified diseases where you know once
you hit 20 you're like you may have a
cough but you're probably you're
probably going to be fine right the
disease is very rare even
in the case that there is an outbreak
where it's circulating somewhere so
we're talking about this mother
wrongly applying the statistical
likelihood of this
asymptomatic relative bringing pertussis
through the door yeah right very low
likelihood for an eight you know I would
say it's perfectly rational almost no
matter what whether there's pertussis in
the world or not it is very irrational
to say hey if you're sick with anything
yeah not now let's do this some other
time or or oh there's a known outbreak
in the city where I live or the city
where you live of something that is
infectious and
one of us isn't vaccinated in a way that
feels protective like no visits not now
not while this has happened not while
this is happening but in general you
know let's not be naive about this fact
is one of the many many things that
should have been obvious
like really should have been obvious in
fact I believe I had a hypothesis on the
table that said
is this known seems like it should be
true is that vaccination can actually
depress your immunity for even a good
vaccine can depress your immunity for a
period of time especially a booster
where what you're doing is you are
delivering a dose of something that your
immune system is already somewhat alert
to because what that does is it occupies
those cells and those antibodies that
are targeted at that thing and so yeah
now and especially like if if we are to
believe
the reports that right now you know
covet is circulating even more and more
really and flu and is it RSV
um like we got you know there's a
apparently and I have not vetted any of
these reports and of course now I take
such reports with a skepticism that I
don't want to have to have but if that
is all true this is not the moment to be
depressing your immune system by adding
a level of security against something
that is not known to be experiencing an
upsearch right and in the case of
pertussis you know has somebody given
you good advice about for what period of
time you're more susceptible to
pertussis because your pertussis
immunity is depressed and at what point
that flips and you go into a more immune
phase so the answer is look you who are
making this policy because you feel it's
right for your child actually don't know
enough to make the policy for your own
house so that it is a positive one you
may in fact be increasing the chances
pertussis will walk through your door
because you don't know what that period
of time over which pertussis immunity is
depressed by the vaccine is going to be
and it's bound to be something yeah so
the answer is look
I'm not coming to your house if I'm sick
with anything I don't think it's a good
idea and I don't want to treat it
casually you know just because it's just
a colder that's what I think it is now
we can even call it you know some number
of days afterwards right like there can
totally bracket this thing totally yeah
so I think I think what I would say to
this person is look I I'm not
insensitive to your concern about your
kid I share it but I don't think that
what you're deploying is actually a
policy that protects your kid I think it
protects you socially from the
horrifying case that somebody delivers
this very rare disease to your house and
let's do something else so that we avoid
that let's agree that if I've been sick
in the two weeks prior to our scheduled
visit I ain't coming and if I wake up
the morning of our visit and I feel
something weird in my throat even if
it's the kind of thing that usually
turns out to be nothing I'm not coming
but if I haven't had any symptoms in
that period of time
let's take normal precautions but the
harm to your child of not being exposed
to their family members because of a
hyper vigilance that doesn't make sense
relative to a disease that's not good
for them either yeah
good
where do we start Zach
okay I was going to say three and a half
billion years ago
generalists seem more needed than ever
but are they wanted
studying data science I'm drawn to
epidemiology ecology Etc but assume I'll
be turned away in an era of expert
fetishism and closet conformists
yeah you're right
you're absolutely right uh
what they are I mean on all parts of it
like they're just absolutely more needed
than ever and
well uh this is a this is the result of
this stupid
funding mechanism for universities that
prioritizes Grant overhead and the fact
is generalists you know are not in need
of some hyper-specialized apparatus that
costs a half a million bucks that will
make the university smile when you
and get a grant for it
um I will I do find the fact
that DeSantis or his team decided to to
call me for this thing positive because
as I said at the thing I don't have the
Specialties that people typically
associate with this but evolutionary
biology is the framework that allows you
to see how all of those Specialties fit
together because they're all
evolutionary
and so anyway maybe maybe we're about to
recognize what the toolkit you and I
have been deploying evolutionary biology
is in fact excellent not only because
it's a cool place to stand but because
it is inherently generalist
it is and it seems
most of the people who wield the toolkit
even with some facility
uh mostly are still speaking from a
specialist platform and so you know they
will do what I was kind of goofing on my
own interests and tenancy in the in the
main episode starting by talking about
squamaids and character Evolution and
and such
um you know I I can geek out all day on
that stuff and I'm really interested to
do so but uh but it's really important
that anyone that can do that who
actually wants to live an informed life
be able to apply the tools that they
have from from whatever it is that
they've done scientifically to as many
things as they can and you know how
the the concern that this person will be
turned away in an expert of fetishism
and closet conformists
I guess it depends on what what exactly
the context there is will there be the
job description for you if you can do a
bunch of different things
maybe not uh I I think
you know the question just assumes that
institutions are functional at all and
they're not but I was sitting on
committees sitting on and chairing
hiring committees
um for a couple decades actually both as
a graduate student and um Anne as a
professor and I watched these job
descriptions evolve and it was sort of
during the era in which the the term
interdisciplinarity became popular and
suddenly you were well it felt sudden
but maybe that was just because it was
punctuated because they're like now I'm
on a job committee I'm in a hiring
committee again it's been two years and
now I'm seeing a lot of like oh we'd
love someone who can do you know this or
this or this or this and uh
someone close to the field might say
whoa wait a minute those are wildly
different things but actually what the
department was saying was actually we
know that we have an interest in all of
these things and we don't actually care
what your specialty is as long as you
come in the door being able to sort of
think broadly and so I was seeing that
in job descriptions and I feel like I
again began to see that contract again
as sort of what what had been an honest
and honorable interest in actual
interdisciplinarity became revealed as a
fetish for a term and in imagining that
to do interdisciplinary work what you
have to do is put one specialist next to
another specialist and see if chemistry
happens and like it doesn't because if
you have two real hardcore Specialists
they don't know how to talk across those
boundaries so everyone has to have the
interdisciplinarity in themselves in
order to actually reach across other
boundaries that they haven't yet
themselves experienced and so you should
be generalists should be exactly what
everyone is hiring for no matter what
you know someone with some depth in one
or more places as well some specialty on
which they can you know wax eloquent for
some amount of time or think carefully
or design experiments to you know
generate hypotheses
um but being able to connect the various
dots is utterly important or else you're
going to do
either fine but not that very not that
interesting Brick in the Wall of science
or you're going to be a Weasley little
conformist who believes fouchy whenever
he stands up and talks all right couple
things
um
you need a certain
quantity
of generalism in order for what you're
doing to work at the University level is
in some sense what you're saying you get
that generalism either by hiring
generalists or you can hire Specialists
who also speak generalists yep you
probably should never hire almost
anybody who can't do that right and I
used to say that one of the ways to fix
peer review is to have papers reviewed
not within the discipline but an
adjacent discipline if you can't explain
it to somebody in an adjacent discipline
it probably isn't worthwhile or
meaningful or true yeah right
um
so generalism is an important ingredient
and you need an awful lot of it to make
the soup function not that soup
functions that's a terrible metaphor but
um
to make a highly functional soup let's
just say that and uh yeah it doesn't
work does it no not at all really it's
not making me recovery nope
um but I love your formulation
that the desire for Specialists is often
a fetish for a particular term that is
so dead on accurate right some term is
hot and suddenly everybody's advertising
themselves as interested in it and
really it just means they're sort of
narrow they're weather veining you know
and it's it's really it's it's bad bad
stuff fashion should have no place in
science but in fact it's become the the
rain of the day it's the way people get
hired because some term is hot when
you're looking for a job and if you're
you know if you're the kind of person
who says Ah that's not my thing but let
me show you what's important that's it
that's worth listening to but oh yeah
I'm on that new thing right well what's
going to happen two years from now and
nobody gives a damn about that thing
yeah
um
yeah I remember one of my I'm not going
to name him by name here but one of my
favorite people faculty members at
Evergreen talking about
um
years ago being interested in the ways
that um DNA got folded in on itself in
chromosomes and being told what the hell
like not not cool not interesting
nothing to see there like there is
nothing there and then long after he got
his degree it like it exploded it's like
oh there's a ton hiding here and this
has to be the thing that you do and it
was like I oh never mind yeah absolutely
yeah no the the the specialist that's
that's that's another excellent point is
the specialization will shield you from
the truly next big thing that's down the
road just far enough that nobody it's
not it's not a fad yet right and yeah
being interested in his Stone wrapping
and and chromosomes was going to be the
key or one of the few keys that unlocked
the epigenetic revolution so yeah
imagine them you know shutting down uh
your friend and my friend over his um
interest in that topic which wasn't hot
yet like boy what a missed opportunity
right and you can you know at some level
uh it's just lucky here that it was what
you were talking about in the main
podcast but you can see the danger of
specialization from your squamate
example because if you specialize too
much within squalmates it leaves you
without a leg to Slither on
although a lot of the squad mates have
legs and some don't and that's why if
you see the whole group then you got
legs and yet they're all tetrapods yeah
yep but not quadrupeds some of them are
some of them aren't yeah we just lost
three more audiences yes we did lose and
I almost heard their eyes rolling to the
point that they may have sprained them
yeah all right uh next question
this past week in one of the Twitter
file drops a new phrase caught my
attention L3 entities these were
mentioned three separate times yet I saw
nearly no one talking about them what do
you think these are
I didn't see any of this so I don't know
do you know you probably oh yeah now
that I'm doing it now that I know the
term I I would like to go back and find
it an L3 entity yeah I just um I didn't
even know whether that's the good people
or the bad people yeah I don't know
sorry
um does it does the L3 entity give
information on who to uh to punish or is
the L3 entity one of the punished
I have no idea um but I will look into
it
um
Brett please explain why you thought
Chappelle's joke was funny but wrong
does funny but wrong even exist it
sounds quite woke to me as a concept
um I don't remember I don't remember
what this is referring to so Chappelle's
joke was that there were two words you
must never put together
the Jews
and
the reason that I thought it was funny
is because I think the sensitivity is
quite right that that sensitivity does
exist and any of us Jewish or not have
to be very careful about discussions in
this area right that's real and I don't
like it one bit in fact what I
understand I have not been to Israel
sadly I would love to go haven't been
yet but what I understand from people
who live there
is that your ability to have such
conversations is greater there than it
is in the U.S which is telling right to
the extent that there is a more vibrant
conversation generally about Judaism
what it is what role it plays in the
world
um you know that's healthy and that part
of the problem is that by shutting down
that discussion we don't get to the
truth which is you know frankly it's a
tough truth right you know are there
Jewish criminal conspiracies No Doubt
are the Jews involved in such
conspiracies highly competent probably
Jews Excel had a lot of stuff I bet they
excel at conspiracy right
is the Jew are there also failed Jewish
conspirations conspirators yes no doubt
no doubt and what's more even to the
extent that you will find that there are
Jewish conspiracies as there are you
know Italian conspiracies that as you
will find mafias of many kinds you will
find a Jewish Mafia right you will also
find uh conspiracies inside the
corporate world and some of them will
have a Jewish character to them because
I don't know it's a diaspora but
the problem is that when a guy like
Chappelle points to this the implication
about that this is somehow directly
connected to what the Jews are can't
help but be derived from it and I guess
what I would love to talk to Chappelle
about is the reality of what he's seeing
and what's not real that you might infer
from it right and anyway so I guess look
to the to the questioner's point
is there such a thing as funny but not
true
yeah there is the degree to which a a
modicum of Truth is necessary in order
for something to be truly funny I won't
say at a hundred percent there's stuff
you know there's absurdist humor that's
not funny that's because of anything
true in it really does get so over the
top you know but
um
the fact that truth and humor bear a
close relationship
but it is not it is not that they are
synonymous with each other is key and so
in in some sense I think the point is
look very few people could say what
Chappelle said and live to tell the tale
right
Chappelle can do it I think that's
awesome and I love that he can do it and
I also think that the point is okay
you've raised a topic that's almost
impossible to raise now that it's raised
can we talk about it that's the point
that joke the fact that that joke is
funny means okay we all get that there's
something over there now can we talk
about what it is and that's the extent
of it I think it's it's a contribution
to the conversation
um because we do need to get to the
point where we can say what it is and
what it isn't good not an answer to the
question but
um you talking about various mafias
it struck me that one of the reasons
that I
uh I you know that all of us I don't
know that it's a reason that all of us
but one of the shows that we have loved
uh and I think is certainly in the top
five TV shows for me and maybe the top
one is peaky blinders and one of the
things that it does That's So marvelous
is in part because the lead figures are
gypsies
who like the Jews of you know have been
roaming people
um unlike the Jews have never you know
been granted a Homeland uh they and and
there is it's basically a criminal
family it's a criminal
outfit uh with you know very rich
characters of both sexes and you know
they do that brilliantly
um but maybe because they're Romani
they're they're gypsies they end up
having to interface with members of the
other mafias and so they end up yes
interacting with the Italian mafia but
also they got Alfie yeah the Jewish guy
yeah and I mean I feel like there's more
and I can't I can't thank all of you
know and one of their employees is and I
don't know if employee is the right word
but is a is a black guy who I think
often appears to be busking on the
street right like I don't even I don't
remember the busking yeah maybe yeah
maybe not
um but they also interact with the North
American Italian mob yeah this is I oh I
guess those are two different mobs
they're two different yeah
Italian-American and Italian mobs
um but the
the sort of the
the pretense of well we we would need
and it's it's based Loosely on a real a
real family from between World War one
and World War II and um
Birmingham
um
they would have needed to make
connections with all the other Mafia
because on their own they would not have
uh enough connections makes for a much
richer story and that is going to be
true of all Humanity right like you know
take the criminal component out of it
and once Force to escape from your own
tribe in order to accomplish what it is
that you want to do you end up being
more interesting being more productive
being likely to be you know better able
to do good for yourself and for for
others
um because because you're outside of
your own tribal boundaries
love this point
here's where I think it goes
we have described that there are
basically two
uh roots for human cooperation
the most fundamental route is genetic
lineage right that because you have
because you share genes it can make a
lot of sense to collaborate with others
because your genes can be spread by
helping them and by them helping you
right it's a natural
the better reason to collaborate is
because it is productive for both of you
it's profitable yeah so you've got
genetic relatedness and you've got
reciprocity
the West is based on the idea that
reciprocity is the thing to follow right
and the idea is not to pretend that some
of us aren't more closely related to
each other than we are to others but the
idea is we profit best when we put
things like race aside and we
collaborate because it's a good thing to
do right we end up being more decent we
end up accomplishing things that we
couldn't otherwise accomplish when you
look at the fraction of
the great inventions of the last couple
hundred years and you find out what
fraction of them emerged from America
this experiment in reciprocity right the
idea that we are a Melting Pot that's
fundamentally what we are and we're
going to collaborate right that is a
demonstration of how powerful this is
compared to the other thing compared to
defaulting to lineage however
when your racism bubbles up and it makes
it difficult for certain people to
collaborate because they are shunned
because of the color of their skin
because of the shape of their noses or
lips or whatever you create this
um bias in the direction of
lineage-based competition and against
reciprocity
and so
the reason I connect this to what you're
saying is that you've got all of these
different mafias and they in effect are
groups of people who typically have
defaulted into this lineage mode of
collaboration presumably because the
opportunities that were available if
they played the game with wherever they
landed right as immigrants does it make
sense
right to play the game collaboratively
with everybody you know irrespective of
their skin color or does it make more
sense is it more profitable to you know
blood is thicker than water to do that
thing and so in any in some sense look
we all get that the mafias are
fascinating because they do something
that we normally can't do and don't do
um they're frightening because they
treat other people as non-entities and
that's part of their superpower and the
point is actually one of these things
makes better television
right the mafia thing makes really good
television and movies
but better Society is made by
egalitarianism and meritocracy where the
questions well how am I going to get
ahead well maybe I should team up with
capable people and I should ignore
whether they're men or women or black or
Asian or whatever I should ignore those
things and I should team up with people
because together what we've got is
greater than the sum of all of the parts
that we individually bring to the table
and so I guess I'm I'm putting it
together it's an argument it's it's it's
the correct argument for diversity it is
the correct argument for diversity and
you know this is this message I I can't
manage to get people to understand which
is look if you break that thing if you
break the uh the Cosmopolitan sense that
we should put race aside do you know
what you're going to get you're going to
get a war of all against all lineage by
lineage you don't want that we've seen
that world that's almost all of human
history that's right right you want the
thing that we recently invented that is
an alternative to it that works way
better we come directly from that and
it'll be
a quick descent back into it and it will
be very hard to recover the the wisdom
of the West yep and we are we are living
that descent it is it is we are we are
playing with fire restoring the lineage
against lineage world and none of us
should want it
all right
here's a recommendation greetings I'm a
big fan of Dr Ken Berry
who is apparently a big fan of yours he
just did a great interview with Dr Aseem
Malhotra I really would like to
interview you as well would love to have
you reach out to him thanks
I don't recognize the name I don't
recognize the name it's possible if I
saw his face I would but
um
but anyway yeah interesting
um have you seen the new study on
myocarditis and moderna very small
sample size but interesting there's a
link here which is a little hard to grab
in this uh
format that we've got I have not seen it
have you done anything about it Brett
nope oh I know I know nothing about any
new study I know that
there was quite a bit of myocarditis the
argument was more from uh from moderna
then from the Pfizer shot the argument
was that it had to do with the modernist
shot being hotter in terms of the
quantity the dosage yeah um I believe
there is something out there's been this
has been bubbling up for a while but I
believe there's something out
that at least has uh
has Ryan Cole
mentioning it in the last week I don't
think he's connected to it directly but
about the question of how homogeneous
were the different Lots
and that part of the issue is that
that's that's come back up as a yeah I
think the argument that is being
Advanced is that basically a lot of
people got blanks which weren't
effective but were a lot less dangerous
too because they just didn't have the
stuff in it
um so anyway I don't know how true that
is but that sounds awfully plausible
yeah I'm looking at the study I that's
the first time I've seen it
autopsy-based histopathological
characterization of biochuditis after
anti-saris Kobe 2 vaccination um
yeah well at least you know autopsy
studies are something that we have not
gotten enough of a lot of this stuff is
presumably unambiguous on autopsy and
the fact that autopsies are not being
regularly done uh is uh an absurdity and
and it's a it's a crime because we need
to know what the effect was and having
uh
doctors survey these tissues and figure
out what went wrong with them is a quick
way there the only reason you wouldn't
do it is if you didn't want the
information yes and it's published in a
journal called clinical research and
Cardiology so that also suggests a focus
on things that have actually happened
gets to the heart of the matter wow
okay
um
great to see your Furry Friends
participating with you you know one of
them's rolling just Out Of Reach
um
great to see your Furry Friends
participating with you please set me
straight on my biological terms our
human relationships with pets symbiosis
mutualism seems too strong a word but
commensalism seems too weak
I would argue that domestication is a is
a process that isn't assumed in those
broader
biological terms frankly there's an
additional process
yeah I would I would say that like many
things
the missing concept is lineage once you
realize that lineage is just as valid
and evolutionary level as individual
then the idea of a
mutualism and I don't distinguish here
between mutualism and symbiosis but the
idea that we have a mutualistic
relationship with our pets is not the
least bit far-fetched now the problem
with cats in particular so remember the
key thing to remember when you know
they're armed right the cats the problem
with cats he begins as if he's safe
they are minimally armed which I
appreciate
the so the key thing to remember with
our two most common
uh pet species is that dogs have an
absolutely anomalously long relationship
with human beings 30 000 years
far longer than anything else as far as
we know we've been domesticating plants
included by a factor of three because
the
everything else is domesticated in
conjunction with farming yeah and dogs
were domesticated as a partner in
hunting and so that relationship is way
way deeper right it and it has modified
dogs even the eyebrow raising weird
stuff that looks like they're signaling
you is a modification of of an Animal by
this Force cats are almost the other end
of the spectrum they were recently
comparatively recently domesticated and
they were domesticated not fully because
their job didn't involve hanging out
with you immediately and communicating
with you directly it involved watching
The Grain and killing the stuff that
eats it
um so anyway they're opposite ends of
that Spectrum which is interesting
hello friend
um
but
what is true for all of the major
domesticates
is the clearing yams
yes
is that all of them
occupy a much larger space on the earth
than they would absent domestication
even you know as you point out yams is
funny because it's a plant but
um but even things that we eat yeah are
experiencing a mutualism because if you
think about the number of goats that
would be on the Earth or the number of
chickens or certainly the amount of rice
right if you think about any of these
things they have gotten this deal where
they you know the cats exist in your
average neighborhood at a density that
no Predator could possibly exist so the
point is the very existence of The
Creatures part of its relationship with
people now when you get to whether or
not our relationship with cats is
properly understood as a mutualism
could be understood as a parasitism in
modern we don't have any grain remember
growing any grain no yeah so if we don't
grow any grain so we're parasizing them
no no well I think somebody if you just
do an individual level argument you
could say oh well they're parasitizing
your well-being you put a certain amount
of your wealth and your your affection
into into that was
that was rude that was rude you put some
of what you've got to spend into your
animals that's them taking advantage of
you that's them making I don't know
baby-like noises and triggering your
maternal and paternal instincts I don't
think so
I think that this actually is I mean the
fact that we find that people who have
such relationships
um get health benefits from them means
that this has become something deeper
that the grain protection relationship
isn't the sum total of it and it's now
become kind of um an emotional
interdependence I know I certainly feel
personally
happier and more rewarded if I come into
a house and if there's nobody home
there's a pet and I can find out what
they're up to and they're glad to see me
and I'm glad to see them so anyway I
would say don't be so afraid of uh
what which term was it that you didn't
want to use mutualism mutualism seems
too strong a word he says he I don't
think so I don't think it's too strong a
word no I don't I don't either
um and I would just argue that
commensalism probably doesn't exist yeah
yeah true and but also I guess um
maybe the thing that I was getting at
with domestication is a process that
usually isn't included in in other
species relationships that are
understood to be mutualisms which is to
say that we're also co-evolving with
certainly with dogs human and dog humans
and dogs are cool
[Music]
wow that was extraordinary if they heard
that
um
but uh humans and cats to some degree
are as well okay the cat is yelling for
crackers it may be too bad as crackers
yeah this is what he eats we are getting
to the end here we're we're driving them
so I just want to make this one sentence
Point commensalism probably doesn't
exist because it's very hard to be
exactly neutral in your effect you could
be slightly positive or slightly
negative being exactly neutral the
chances are vanishingly small and let me
give the example
a classic commensalism that would be in
your textbook would be like a bird that
builds a nest in a tree right and the
answer is it's not sucking resources
from the tree but it is probably
dropping a little guano on the tree that
could be positive it is shading out the
leaves that fall below the nest even if
it builds it you know it's putting a
little bit of extra weight on the branch
right so the point is what are the
chances that averaged over all of the
trees that get one of these nests that
it's actually exactly zero the chances
are exactly zero yeah well and even even
if one individual Nest actually does
average to zero the idea that the inject
that species has an exactly zero effect
on that on that tree like that's not
going to happen yeah I mean and I would
say
as a theorist we can even do away with
the possibility that any Nest has ever
been exactly zero by saying well then
measure finer right one Photon was
blocked somewhere along the line yeah
you know
uh Elon is sitting with Lex Friedman
next week can you come with one or two
of the most worthwhile questions you'd
like Elon to look into
um
yeah I would say
the
foreign
well it depends a little bit with the
question about uh hey buddy
um about whether or not
this is about General stuff or stuff
that Elon is already up to but on the
topics that Elon is already working on I
think he I understand I think what he's
doing with respect to moderation of
um Twitter
but he needs to
um he needs a red team
and he needs
uh he needs a group
to
in conversation with each other
generate a
SEC Sac Fairfax is right there Fairfax
right there
sorry guys
um
hey oh where are you going Turtle chaos
here okay so if I can rephrase what I
was trying to say sorry we were both a
little worried about uh
um yeah
Elon needs a red team
he also needs a group of people which
might be the red team team or it might
be a different team to discuss possible
mechanisms for moderating Twitter
and I think he needs to free himself
from the idea that he's going to post a
perfect set of rules I am fairly
convinced by lots and lots of years
about thinking about these sorts of
things that what he needs to do
is specify the values that the rules are
supposed to accomplish and the needs to
empanel people to utilize discretion
with the understanding that it will not
be perfect it has to be non-biased but
it will not be perfect so um none of
those is questions those are things that
you think you should do I I haven't I
don't you and I were talking about this
this morning I don't the question is how
do you moderate Twitter but the answer
is he's going to moderate Twitter
personally and then he's going to make
mistake after mistake and he will learn
but he will pay a huge price for each of
those errors and the way to do it
properly is to say let's let's speed up
the process of evolution let's impanel
some people to figure out what
mechanisms might be deployed and then
you have a red team that looks at those
mechanisms and says okay I'm going to
throw challenges at you if you write
this rule here's the thing you can't
moderate correctly right and if you put
those two things in concert with each
other
you will discover what you might do but
I think the punch line of the story will
be you need a body that can exert
discretion over a set of values that are
agreed upon that everybody who signs up
agrees to
and I will also say that I've had
several discussions about how you might
make that scale right because the
problem is if you decide that discretion
is the root of good moderation then how
do you going to moderate every tweet how
do you how do you moderate every tweet
that is flagged so someone else asks
maybe in response to this question can
we all float one simple question to Elon
is Twitter a carrier or a publisher
thank you
um
I don't unfortunately that question is
not elon's to answer that's a section
230 question and so the federal
government has given us a well delivered
us a mess
yeah but he could apply consistency
he could apply consistency couldn't he
he could he could say you know what I
view it as a or b and therefore the
decisions that we make are based on that
well I don't think we understand his
predicament well enough the problem is
that this is a
uh a legal distinction and so what he
does has implications
that
I I don't I don't know what they are if
he behaves one way or the other so
anyway I I can't answer that okay that
that is a that is a problem inscribed
into the law based on Section 230 and
somebody is going to need to deal with
Section 230 in order that we're not
constantly on the losing end of both
definitions
okay
um there are several more questions here
most of them are about things that I
actually just haven't seen so let me
quickly get through a couple of them and
if you have something quick to say say
it but I think mostly we just any
comment on the study which warns
subvariance BQ and xbb have alarming
ability to evade both immunity and
Medical Treatments and boosters
I don't know this study I can't speak to
it yeah
uh can you offer any advice on the newer
novovax code vaccine I cannot find much
info on its safety or Effectiveness as
an alternative to mrnas
I can't tell from the question if they
say newer meaning
it came out after the MRNA vaccines or
if there's a newer there's a new Nova
Vex I think it is the former and I will
say I haven't looked very deeply I do
believe it's Spike based which means the
degree to which it can be safe is
limited yeah May well be better
certainly the lipid nanoparticles carry
their own hazards the MRNA mechanism
carries its own Hazard
so it could well be better but my
question is how long are we going to
keep playing this Spike game before we
realize that that choice was an error to
begin with yeah
uh on Eric's tweets with regard to 1A
principles being dependent on social
mores do you agree can such mores be
evolutionarily stable and if so what
traits or conditions I don't know the
tweets so I can't respond I don't either
um
Heather could you tell about your lard
it all beauty tips please
um lots of love to both of you
maybe another time maybe when it's not
so late and the cat isn't yelling
um but yeah I do like I do like the lard
based uh
Pharaoh Pharaoh Pharaoh life yeah
um it's it's quite good
um yeah another another time
uh let's do one
more
socio-political and cultural problems
are Downstream of cowardice some
cowardice might even be hardwired
EG neuroticism how do we teach courage
to those who don't have it
uh well teach is a tough one yeah right
if you have Generations you can teach
you can put people in circumstances that
push them just slightly beyond the limit
where they can get the sense that things
don't immediately go Haywire they can
develop the skills that allow them to
manage that they can feel positive about
not feeling cowardice and facing things
courageously and that's let me I know
you're going somewhere but like that's
what that's what could happen with a
full-time educational environment like
at Evergreen and like nowhere else right
that if you have even just a full
quarter but especially a full year with
people wherein
um it becomes clear that no one is there
to win points but actually to discover
truth you can actually
teach the value of being courageous at
least mentally courageous and depending
on you know the program physically
courageous psychologically courageous as
well and that really is one of the
biggest things that you simply
it's maybe impossible but certainly very
much harder to do if you're talking
about you know if you're talking about
teaching in a traditional way like okay
we've got like a teacher student
relationship if you're meeting three
times a week for 50 minutes
there's not gonna be a lot of trust that
can be established and there's just not
going to be the time to push you know to
push each other around and to have it be
revealed like oh yeah I pushed you
around and I come back and I still
respect you and like you can't like my
disagreeing with you does not indicate
that I think you're a bad person
um so teach is tough teach well teach
isn't tough if you have the structure in
the standard environment how are you
going to teach a population to be more
courageous yeah you can't yeah in the
structure that allows it but what you
can do is recognize that courage surely
exists in something like a normal
distribution or a power law of
distribution
and that that means that what you have
is a full spectrum
of different levels of Courage that
exist in people as you find them and the
key thing to recognize is that
those who have lots of Courage can make
things safer for those who have slightly
less and so if the people who have lots
of Courage stand up
then it creates cover for people who
have slightly less to stand up which
creates cover for the next level and so
it kind of uh
contagious courage is a very real thing
and unfortunately
our antagonists have sort of spotted it
and so what they do is they make it so
that you do not see the lesson in front
of you so that
um you know if the idea is well I don't
this person sounds good I wonder who
they are and then you go look at their
Wikipedia page and you find vile
Slanders that may be the point is well I
don't know what that is but I'm oh that
person's a crazy anti-vaxxer yeah oh
geez that's that's disappointing yeah so
anyway
you're gonna have to tune out the thing
that doesn't want you to encounter the
people who might know the thing that you
would benefit from knowing yep
that's right okay well this got a little
chaotic at the end here but yeah
apologies for that we had we've
attempted cat escapes and curious other
situations
um
we'll be back we'll be back in six days
we'll come back to you on Friday
December 23rd with live stream 154. I
haven't yet decided if we're gonna do a
q a we probably will
um yep but uh
but there it is and then tomorrow uh
join us at 11 A.M Pacific for uh the
private q a which is which feels a lot
different from this it's it's
awesome too but in a different way it is
um so
we're not even the same people as that
points out yeah they were monstrous I
think
um but before the next live stream we've
got
Hanukkah
yes starting today tomorrow
all right uh so happy Hanukkah Merry
Christmas
uh would be right before Christmas
forget it
um if you want to be wished a merry
Christmas with the solstice so happy
Solstice We Wish You a Merry Christmas
the day before four days before all
right you can tell I'm not good with
calendars
no that's gonna come out uh between
Christmas time
we don't believe in calendar Street yes
okay that was my foot doggie
um boy we are so out of here
so out of here until we see you next
time be good to the ones you love eat
good food and get outside be well
everybody